now just before you've on this thing
here why do you think it's useful why
don't you stay included yeah
comparison is really important when
you're trying to monitor how much
utility you usually and how much money
you're spending on it so for example I
noticed there's a big change between
this bill and the same period last year
now the first question I'm going to ask
is why don't even have the same period
last year
why do they compare um this type of time
this year versus this chunk of time
watching why is that important
[Applause]
[Music]
fluctuating much electric fantastic so
let me ask you this what do you think
what would you guess be that is actually
seasonal when would you get is the time
of the year that you use the least
electricity frame interest rate in
Australia summers when you use the most
electricity because cooling things down
it's a long shower then heating things
up you believe so I are to the least of
them what do you think the least what is
it it's going to be a bit of a time
between autumn spring this one does
fluctuate year to year let me ask you
this we've already said ah okay summer
is hot so we put this down
winter is cold so we do want these up so
be one of these temperate times which
the I mean just as an approximate which
do you think would be for pal just take
a guess let me ask you the same where do
people tend to Wenders um the our arid
Vibram when we tend to get the most rain
okay now I don't teach geography I do
know for example we have had a
particularly rainy autumn my jebel
barkal you know ah yes the thing you
historically I think mostly you say
Street in fact that's why we call them
spring rains all I'm pointing out is
when it's rainy we do ten to use
willpower you will know why okay
so stupid for life okay usually it has
to do with humidity if it's really humid
see what I like it to be really cubed it
cause lots of homeless not just
discomfort so what do we do achieve it
you turn on usually the distributor fire
or the air conditioner any of every
month is the first half of the engine
yes what do you need an entire you've
got it by so you've got humidifiers and
dehumidifiers which are useful at
different climates a humidifier wait for
it makes things humid right so for I'm
not walking for example if you go to a
really dry place and really dry and hot
place what you'll find is like like many
parts of Australia paint just peels off
outside the house inside the house
because if your paint is water-based
which a lot of people are then you'll
dry out and will flake off if you if you
live in a house between the old that's
what happens so it's not a feud enough
then this causes problems for your
structure so you might want to cube it a
five year there also like health
benefits of my okay
dehumidifiers surprise you is less
serious
I doesn't change the temperature at
least not intentionally it just changes
how much in water content is in here
let's move on
another nice type agent it says when we
asked you guys which question party the
cost of usage is broken down into peak
energy rate shoulder energy charge and
off-peak energy charge
okay of course I don't I'm not
interested in a where it is but why is
there such a thing as pick a topic why
is there such a thing as two different
times times people doing on Sunday okay
so a lot of power usage is just
consistent all the time in fact one of
the biggest values in your house is on
24 hours a day seven days a week
you can't ever switch it off otherwise
you're it's a problems don't know it is
your fridge and your freezer right so
they're going all the time but there are
some things which are early on some of
the time example what ah more examples
yeah TV you know there are things that
people are on with yo okay all right now
interestingly so I'm going to say things
like TV because someone is really to
watch it likes because only in certain
periods of the day but I'm going to
pause then washing machine because this
is actually a very important counter
example washing machines are often used
to a particular type of the day but we
can control when we use it and there's a
really good reason to do that so you
don't know how long typical wash cycle
is it'll vary depending on how many
clothes you're washing and how dirty
your clothes are do the washing you guys
should find it down it'll vary between
an hour if it's just like your daily
like chapter shared it's not that dirty
but it need to wash up to four hours
four hours a really long time but if you
have an energy-saving washing machine
we're going to talk about those later
but my cycle goes for four hours and 15
minutes wow that's a really long time
okay now just think about this okay
let's get for a weekend okay you wake up
on a weekend if the first thing that you
do is put the washing machine off for a
4 hour and 15 minutes cycle what time is
it going to be when it finishes what
went on you wake up and you just give me
a [ __ ] last
you're going to miss most of the summer
and walk of the day right so instead of
waiting until you first wake up to put
the machine on what are you going to do
instead good night put on a timer so
that you haven't think about when it's
going to start so that when you wait
guard
it's just finished and ready to go okay
now why did this make sense it's not
just because I want to you know get the
right time of the day
okay but energy costs well I understand
ceiling but energy electricity takes
energy to create there's only certain
amounts of generators out with what does
it all remember when the minute bad
weather really bad heat wave came
through and it's 40 degrees what did the
government asked to do it's a don't put
on your air conditioning instead yeah
and died okay
scallop or go to a shopping center
because they're not going to switch the
aircon off right and I wonder if you
guys walk through life under natural
foods or something like that and the
skin will just off City or couches they
don't shop it they just or convert our
oil you're going to tell is it it's like
is no shock to you people just sitting
there right now the reason why because
there's not some limitless supply of
electricity we just dip into right what
kinds of ways we generate electricity
Oh Cole L yeah I can gasps we I'm so
loud dance hydro the chicken okay but my
point is that by an infinite amount okay
so they want you not to use it all at
the same time
so therefore have a look look on the
page where do you see information about
pick a topic there's two places you can
see it can you tell me the two places
Danielle school never heard of it
yes bees as well so pink it's not
because energy costs more money to use
it a particular time all they're trying
to do is discourage you from using it at
peak times does that make sense it's not
like oh oh no it's 6:00 p.m.
electricity is magically more expensive
now to actually get at the same cost all
the time they just want to push you
towards using a particular terms peak of
people
what do you think shoulder is so I if
you've got spots on your page I want you
to draw a little rough graph I want you
to label it costs and time what do you
think peak time is I probably say right
to the time that's that's my guess
because because everyone the light come
on cooking comes on all kinds of things
happen okay so let's just call bullets
say ah you've got 12 midnight okay let's
put so Amir this let's put nude in the
middle so that you come back to midnight
again okay so I would estimate peak time
here's 6:00 p.m. right there right in
between in between 12:00 noon and 12:00
midnight so in between there electricity
costs lots I've got a High Line up there
okay at other times I'm just going to
simplify this and all the times maybe it
doesn't cost as much so it's a bit lower
okay but they don't just flip the switch
and say well we went from cheap too
expensive they have this period where it
transitions right like that okay so that
transition period that's the shoulder
right in between peeps and off people so
that's the rough idea and you can see
the costs that are associated with that
if you have a look up we've actually
skipped over the question itself it said
what percentage of usage occurred in the
shoulder periodically is that what
percentage 80/20 50.5 all right then it
also asks how about the off peak period
in your head so would be 14.5 for
frequent so now when you look at the
questions you'll need to skip two pages
and it says okay let's look at the peak
time and I'll tip off peak times it now
asks what's the peak energy rate per
kilowatt hour that's the cost that
doesn't come down and this usage
breakdown so look back up
whether you complete energy rate that's
the cost
what does it have a look
take energy rate peak energy rates 47.7
I think it's is no bottom
I think it's that over there yeah okay
you can shop Dima I don't like the
clothes yeah which would that be come on
right next time so so we're looking at
part you're acting a party and it says
the cost of usage is so the first
question is just how much usage was in
the shoulder period
what percentage of usage will come to
the column in the second yeah we're
going to answer this process question
very shortly um the way that you can do
ok cos in a second I'm going to leave
you to your own devices right
it says peak energy rate right so I'm
looking for peak energy can you see
where it says that over here is tech
energy right and it says rate but then
when you look across to the right
there's a whole bunch of numbers how do
you know which what is the rate seen at
that rate so this column all of these
are the rates for time yes change okay
so let me distinguish right the cost of
electricity for you the cost you have to
pay changes based on time okay but the
cost of making electricity it's very
different
like from 1 p.m. to 2 p.m. there's
nothing that makes the factories work
different is that they're trying to
discourage you from everyone using at
the same time absent company make it
more fun well these rates are generally
set by the government so question yes in
England just after that in tendencies
and the engine until the fall they would
have to increase the powerful powerful
hatin it rose from the kettle yep yeah
no it hasn't that specifically but
here's the idea right if you are a
government and you want you to encourage
something heavies and discourage other
ones the may the main thing we do is we
just use economics if you make something
expensive less people will do it that's
why if you ever notice if you have a
like take a bus into the city just look
out when the bus is going along at all
way right and you'll notice the signs on
the side of the road when it says cost
for this vehicle that vehicle the cost
has are like a variable part in it
because they change based on the time
since that makes sense they want you to
travel during off-peak thank you okay
roba start for the parts I'm going to
guide you through right there with 12
agencies last what we're going to do
together what's the difference between
the peak and off-peak rates per kilowatt
hour
all right look carefully which ones
picking which ones are P you just told
me the pink it's forty seven point seven
seven eleven point nine is our peak so
what are you going to do with these two
numbers you're going to subtract okay
that will give you a number and that is
the answer what's the difference okay